tonight chicago police they
are identifying the hero officer killed
in a traffic stop over the weekend her
name
ella french i doubt you know her name or
any of the nearly 150 police officers
killed in the line of duty
so far this year alone 29 years old
joined the department in 2018
her brother called her the epitome of a
good samaritan
in an interview with the chicago tribune
a second officer also critically injured
in the shooting over the weekend chicago
police gathered at the hospital
they turned their backs on the failed
far left mayor lori lightweight
who refuses to take any of this violence
seriously
and refuses to take steps to increase
safety and security in chicago
nothing but a national disgrace now
breaking tonight charges have been filed
against two brothers in connection with
the fatal shooting
here with reaction leo 2.0 terrell
chicago
alderman raymond lopez is back with us
raymond we had 73 people shot in your
city this weekend 11 died
including this officer and the one we're
praying for
you're you know how do we have numbers
that high every weekend
you don't hear about the people's names
and it continues how does it keep
continuing
week after week after week i don't want
to report on this anymore i'm tired of
reporting on innocent people getting
shot and shot and killed
i'd love for us to talk about something
positive one day sean
about the city of chicago but the fact
of the matter is that we've had 38
officers shot at in the city of chicago
since lori lightfoot
has been mayor this year alone we had
ella french
who was gunned down and viciously
murdered this past weekend
and i think the lesson that we've
learned is that the only thing more
dangerous than the gang bangers and
criminals on the streets of the city of
chicago
is mayor lori lightfoot and her failed
belief that she is in charge and helping
the city of chicago
she is as you said an absolute failure
and i think it's time that we start
having
discussions on whether or not she needs
to step aside because clearly she is
unable
to protect the people or the police
you know rambo dead fish same thing
you know leo we talk about this a lot i
mean
this woman is 29 years old 73
people shot this weekend but we don't
know their names do we uh leo
no we won't know their name because they
don't focus on the victims
and i want to say bravo to those
officers because they were not going to
be used
as a photo op i'm glad you shunned lori
lightfoot
because everyone knows that lori
lightfoot does not care
about police officers they were
basically being used and they turned
their back on her
because she has been a non-supportive
police officer
her and i really am critical of the
media
her speech today was nothing more than
snake oil she's a frost she doesn't
support police
no police officer in chicago should ever
look at her they should always turn
their back on her
always yeah
for two years lori lightfoot has
vilified the police and now she says
divisive rhetoric must stop she has
fueled that rhetoric
blaming the police time and time again
she has brought us to this point
29 years old you should run against her
if you're serious alderman you should
run against her you should run against
her
one thing i support the police by the
way i definitely support the police i'll
be down
leo would you consider running we need
somebody that's going to stop this i'll
come down there and support you
sean i will say this i'm 100 percent
committed to ensuring
that she does not get a second term my
city cannot survive
two terms of lori lightfoot we have to
put an entity in chicago
in 20. 73 people a 29 year old cop
is dead wake up we need a pro
pro police candidate find a pro police
candidate in chicago hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else